Slumberland is a movie about dreams
starring Jason Momoa from Stargate
Atlantis and this is my review
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
before we get into this video I would
like to announce a new project from
sidetrack 9chevrons.com
is your dedicated source for Stargate
news which will aim to complement this
YouTube channel with news that we have
from our contacts at MGM and Amazon
breaking news about a new potential
Stargate series as well as providing
reviews and any potential updates to
news stories now I've been seeing
trailers for this movie for quite some
time and I really wanted to watch it
because Jason Momoa is in it and I
really really really like James Momoa
not just because he's a previous cast
member of Stargate but I genuinely think
he's a fantastic actor but the trailer
dropped for Slumberland and it is a
movie which is well this thing is fair
to say it's geared towards kids and
being a parent myself I took the
opportunity to sit down with my kids put
the movie on and we watched it together
and oh my God the movie is amazing now
I'm not one for watching movies that
often if you've ever seen me in a live
show every time Jay or stormy or Harris
mentions a movie the chances are I've
probably not seen it because I'm just
not the kind of person to sit down and
watch a movie I will happily sit there
and binge Stargate all day long I'll
watch Doctor Who I've watched Dexter and
Breaking Bad so many times like TV
series I can binge but I just never sit
down and watch a movie but this was an
exception I went into this thinking that
it's gonna be a kids movie so my
expectations aren't going to be
extremely high for it the kids are
probably going to enjoy it but but I
personally will probably just think it's
okay and the main thing will just have
been spending time with my kids but oh
my God even if you don't have children
and you typically don't like watching
children's movies you have to watch this
film it is so good I'm going to give you
a brief synopsis of what the movie's
about but I'm not going to give you any
spoilers the movie follows a young girl
named Nemo who were introduced to at the
beginning of the film living with her
dad in a lighthouse within the opening
act of the film her father goes out on a
boat because he has to go do Lighthouse
duties and unfortunately he dies she is
then sent to live with her uncle in the
city which is a massive change for her
she's never been to school and she's
always lived on that little island with
the lighthouse so going to a big city
with a school it was a massive
adjustment for her however she was able
to visit her previous home via the
Dreamland every night when she went to
sleep she was able to go to sleep and go
back to her childhood home and it's
there that she meets the character known
as flip played by Jason Momoa now her
father had been telling her bedtime
stories ever since she was a little girl
stories of Adventure and heroism
involving him and his Outlaw partner
flip
now when she enters the Dreamland and
she's visiting her childhood home she
Encounters this character known as flip
who is looking for a map the map is
supposed to lead to the seal nightmares
a place where you're not supposed to go
when you're dreaming
it's where all the nightmares come from
it's full of full of dead mythical
creatures
and it's a place of Despair but in the
sea of nightmares there are these orbs
that if you were to obtain one of them
you can make a wish and whatever you
wish for will appear in your dreams
the story follows Nemo and flip
basically going on an adventure to try
and recover some of these orbs in an
attempt for her to be able to see her
dad once again in the Dreamland
but something we also discover is flip
is in the Dreamland and he's forgotten
who he was in the real world
he never woke up so flip being a very
selfish character is only going to
deceive nightmare so he can figure out
who he is I'm not going to tell you
anything else other than that you have
to watch the movie to find out what
happens but it is such a good movie
honestly the big reveal in the film I
kind of guessed it anyway but that's
just because I'm an adult and the film
isn't catered to me it's catered to all
his children so I wasn't upset that I
had guessed the massive twist in the
film
but honestly it is such a fun film to
watch it's a film that will make you
laugh it will probably make you cry and
Jason Momoa in it is fantastic he's more
of a silly character he's not really
that serious he is a very characterized
version of this outlaw but honestly it's
fantastic and I really really really
urge you to go and watch it because as
an adult watching that film with my kids
it was amazing my kids loved it I loved
it my partner loved it and this is going
from two people who generally don't
watch films that that much but let me
know have you seen Slumberland and what
did you think of it if you have remember
don't leave any spoilers in the comments
because there are people who haven't
seen it yet and I really hope all you
star trackers have had a fantastic
Christmas and a really good New Year
welcome to 2023 Sidetrack is going to be
amazing over the next 12 months and some
of the news that is going to come out is
going to be fantastic I really can't
wait to share some of it with you but
thank you so much for watching if you
did enjoy this video make sure you hit
subscribe and press the Bell
notification so you don't miss a single
video also whilst you're down there
consider becoming a fully fed side
tracker hit the join button down below
thank you so much for watching and I'll
see you next time
[Music]